souvent on dit que les milieux humides
valent rien parce qu'on peut pas
développer dedans puis le régime foncier
présentement est fait comme ça au Québec
plus que un terrain a de la valeur c'est
parce que on peut développer puisqu'on
peut y habiter c'est très entrepôt
centré que c'est très reposé sur la
vision de l'humain on a vraiment un faux
sentiment au niveau de la valeur des
milieux naturels
[Musique]
les milieux humides il y en a partout
sont répandu notamment beaucoup dans le
nord du Québec mais le problème c'est
que dans la vallée du Saint-Laurent on a
beaucoup drainé les milieux humides pour
en faire des zones agricoles des milieux
résidentiels donc on dit que 80% des
milieux humides dans la zone la vallée
du Saint-Laurent n'existe plus
ce qui reste il devrait tous être
protégés
le rôle d'un milieu humide c'est de
prendre l'eau qui arrive d'un bassin
versant qui de la filtrer quand on parle
de filtration c'est que les plantes
aquatiques vont venir s'alimenter
finalement des éléments nutritifs qui
vont capter ce qu'on leur donne
les milieux humides ont aussi un
important pour retenir l'eau
ça va avoir d'autant plus d'importance
dans le futur parce que les pluies vont
se rapprocher vont être de plus en plus
importantes donc ces milieux-là vont
absorber vont infiltrer puis quand on va
avoir des périodes de sécheresse un
autre chose qui va arriver avec l'impact
des changements climatiques c'est au
lieu qu'il va avoir été infiltré par les
milieux humides va être relâché dans
l'environnement
ça vient aussi recharger les nappes
phréatiques
le rôle du milieu humide est indéniable
en milieu urbain parce que souvent on a
l'impression que l'humain est capable de
tout reproduire et capable de faire des
bassins de rétention puis de retrouver
facilement les mêmes fonctions qu'un
milieu humide mais malheureusement la
nature est vraiment mieux fait
quand on parle de d'inondation on en
entend souvent parler dans les médias
les inondations sont souvent reliées au
fait qu'on a imperméabilisé un
territoire qu'on a construit dans son
milieu finalement on a construit dans le
lit de la rivière et dans les milieux
humides l'eau fait juste se trouver une
place donc si on détruit encore d'autres
milieux humides il y aura de plus en
plus d'inondations
[Musique]
il y a plein d'habitats diversifiés dans
un dans un milieu humide ce qui fait que
on se retrouve avec une forme
diversifiée on peut voir de la grande
forme comme l'orignal qui va venir se
nourrir des nénuphars mais on peut aussi
voir ici plus de 200 espèces d'oiseaux
dans les prochains mois dans les
prochaines années on aura beaucoup de
défis au niveau urbanistique au niveau
de l'aménagement du territoire pour
s'assurer de la protection des milieux
humides
malheureusement on développe encore sans
penser que l'impact qu'on aura sur
l'hydrologie des cours d'eau notamment
il y a moyen de le faire de développer
autrement puis c'est vraiment des défis
que on doit faire avec les urbanistes
les groupes environnementaux mais aussi
de travailler avec les citoyens qui
veulent protéger ces milieux humides
c'est important de faire des décisions
en pensant aux générations futures qui
eux aussi vont vouloir profiter de la
nature des lacs des rivières donc pour
protéger nos milieux hydriques on doit
vraiment penser à demain puis les élus
ont cette responsabilité là de penser
aux générations futures